[Music]
a little bit of a pissed-off mood but I
could
how does the ensign now we're number
plays we're between the lines we do I
say so now I know the nella know we can
be 20% owners 50% owners or 0% owners
here are the prices right and you make a
lot of profit there right and then and
but you have to make this 1.5 million
dollar investment for us to even
consider this what I'm saying is if
you're ready massively ROI positive with
the sponsorship you know II make you
well then and that yoke right the
hospitality long the short term
profitable we're in a good spot so just
super excited about getting into a new
genre obviously now with the pure while
asset I'm playing in the publishing arm
and so deploying my talents on strategy
and then and business against a huge
platform one of the largest female media
sites and I'm very confident that much
like the wine business and the
advertising businesses the every
business I touch the things are going to
happen so I'm really enjoying the
intermingling and and strategizing with
Ryan who is an incredibly accomplished
CEO who took that from zero to what it
is and I'm excited for him to see the
values on providing in the way that I
see the world and different strategies I
think a lot of times people Zone in on
my hustle as my differentiator if you're
deploying massive hustle against bad
ideas you lose so I need to start on I
almost downplay my strategic ability
because I think that there's some
natural talent in that and I want to
give advice that is more controllable
and I think work ethic is that I just
genuinely don't think you develop being
a better strategically there's a lot of
talent in it so I don't go there but
it's a part of my equation when you get
here by accident
these are good ideas
a good idea to launch a second it was a
good idea to launch a website in 1996
instead of a second liquor store now
unite pretend the market launch the
second liquor store it was a good idea
to take a lot of the money that was
going to catalogs and direct mail and
put it into Google AdWords 99% of the
market was doing catalogs was a good
idea to start a blind show on YouTube
and everybody told me I was crazy even
my inner circle because what was the
value of that it was a good idea idea
and idea that I did that web show I mean
I go on switch it up they say stop
making those sad songs but I'm bad gong
because I'm never going to conform to
mainstream values that's wrong and I
think it's crazy what I've done here
when its platform I'm now here like
Eileen you're wiping the cream of the
crop on that store and all that residue
was great the records like you simple
join the cult I'm in the TV tuxedo
looking boys but neither one for the 32
volts they don't even know when I'm
putting down with a cold crave likes
most general Zeng I'm gonna fire now I'm
storming into your quake jokes I don't
expect anyone to get that reference it's
your preference but if you do it in that
dope of us to walk through the smoke
throws that nobody chokes this is my
version of welding and welding and
welding until I am ready to go I want to
change how they see me but not change
the person is sad that I already know
and by Facebook for series of meetings
this Deb Levin head down to San
Francisco persons meanings catch up with
some startups invested in and then head
back up here and have some more meetings
leading on meetings meetings like the
head room they're like they become one
with my ears getting close to legs of
sleeping with them if we can speak in
Romania excited about that what I've
been to Romania this is a spotty 900
business professionals it's my mom
behind this big hype video they're going
to let you like I feel like a camera
here I feel so weird you're gonna have
some pointed out over that big sign that
the Facebook one hacker way can see that
side the main we walk in is so epic I
think it's very black and white I think
that I live in a world when my friends
are in the war bees and the goobers and
the Airbnb is and I wrote the first
check in the Birchbox and I watch all
these behaviors and it's working at
least the weirdest life like my calendar
is so funny right off there with a
company that's gone from view of 130
million in revenue on the back of
Facebook daily or something else and
then I go into another meeting and and
they're spending 50 percent of their
money by programmatic Digital banners
and they're like proud that they've gone
digital and so we're having incremental
conversations versus the actual
conversation which is how in the world
can we sit here in January 2017 and not
understand that the behaviors that we're
doing are not working when all the macro
data shows that they're not working it's
not working space is struggling CPG is
getting CPG top like I'm just bringing
it back to that just so you have empathy
like everybody's got their own headaches
that's channel conflict war of CPG and
their retailers in the next one years is
going to be insane if nothing else as
big as your companies are doesn't it
make sense for you to do to aid
testing and put real mind behind
something like whether you believe in
Facebook or Twitter or whatever the hell
you think is snapchat I don't care
isn't just interesting to find out if
that's a truth today that's been the big
punchline like it's financially smart
just to call their bluff nothing scares
me
I'm the least scared guy you know going
to come visit hike obscure shoeless
telling tourists now hit him good get it
like one of those I love water parks I
would do like roller like there's
something that happens with water that
doesn't scare like I'll go like are
those really like when why like it is
you like I'm fine but like on roller
coasters I don't like it for some reason
maybe I feel more I'm trying to figure
out my more control like I don't know
we've got like that's an important
variable for me for continuation that we
can like design and get things up within
an hour you know oh I want my team to
visit I want one of the three of us to
design yeah I don't know about that but
find out right away and get back to me
okay yes yeah one of the three guys I'm
some design team I'm going to do it I'm
going to do rock texture right now
they're gonna work the design will be
done within an hour okay all right
wow I didn't know that you see that
watch us okay
it stops it what does with the air bond
[ __ ] it out and then wait that's product
since the iPhone itself
cool so just want to say what's up and
let you guys know that I'm about to do a
20 minute meeting giveaway with me on
Instagram about put an important quote
card full picture and I'm recalling the
60-second Club so I highly recommend
2400 of you go and activate your
notifications and I'm going to post them
mixed very short bit I've gone four
minutes and then after that so maybe in
19 minutes or so hey did you see souls
like some dead sock it's worth it don't
be me feeling like the exact day maybe
having picked a roll-on like fact
envelopes a mailman leave them alone and
make like you most of that that mean II
thought it's only to the rules say
you've got to limit no wonder I'm only
feeling blue uses in the air but my
future's in the air that the same day
time like I got beauty in the air on
can't because if you ain't broke runs
can't how about you coming out if you
don't know work in no way so funny
no way to buy it no way to earn me it's
not my be demerit there's a way that we
deserve it but it's no kazusa perfect
I'm very funny no competition but so you
know I play to win in access me a boss
for many Holly do it
no that's how I've been doing it from
the start you know my name my beautiful
my name leading to my name's Oliver
Stone lasted 45 days so my words on
earth in forty sake case Hey Oh
visionary with the havoc on equipment
hundred honey nothing's automatic
overall oh man yes
are you a while I only see you on your
living your life through Instagram
business Basilio John Garrett real
pleasure house thanks good going to be
here this is the fired up how's it going
good yeah yeah I'm saying he's really
really hit me up yours I look bro you
like text me you like bro
I just put two eggs into a bowl and put
in June like I don't know
so the greatest fish of all time to get
out or like you the magic standing the
rivet angle will come back a little bit
[Music]
we're in that's not a room cool
guys para Joon want to be actually I
think Joon was the first investment I
made in the vayner/rse fund because I
made the commitment to you at South by
Southwest and then I had to drag you out
to actually give you the money to took a
four months longer to create to be Mike
fun my deal you got your favorite man
known you a long time and I claim I'm a
guy so Twitter I'm Gary die phone that's
my claim to fame but you know you're
like that I don't need a long time we
are good for our commitment yes that
like it's not going to come in to like
seven eight months after as opposed to
but I'm going for you know that yep
please let this happen
yeah you literally get run over for you
okay I remember you lots of fun that you
were sure you're true so that's where I
am right now with peace and some content
it is pretty amazing and I think a lot
of you will get it yeah I'm AJ's
obsessed with it like completely
obsessed I always think that you need to
have a gateway product to get you into
where the world's going it's fascinating
to me of how I tell some of my friends
about Jun I'm like look you need a Jun
not just because you should be cooking
your food more efficiently or you should
be saving money over a one-year period
but you as a human should start getting
adjusted to the reality of society we're
going to work and live within over the
next three four five decades and I
actually genuinely believe the following
just like I did about the iPhone which
played out to be true that people that
work and interact with things like Jun
or an Alexa or things of that nature are
actually just going to have better lives
over the next two three decades because
there's any faster movers into this
mortification of all of our products in
other words mate look look through your
work man Thank You Man okay arrest James
James and I read all of your book
crushes question yeah couple years ago
thank you for loved it
thank you so much is real information on
quick thank you bro yes I love your
videos never thank you
well they take it Travis how he's very
good a think about it
pretty shitty camera yeah good yeah out
of the video yeah one really well right
I can do the video thing yeah I'm not
wrong it's a real pleasure math explain
hello I buy sugar yeah thank you
focusing manually or is the camera just
not very good the both of your dad's
events have you ever tried a cannon eat
it do I so guess what I came up with one
Tyler just showed me you'll get you'll
get an email you're approved for CF
that's all set number to call same page
all right love is here
when you learn how to turn the cliche
45-minute [ __ ] meeting that all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] are doing everyday in
to let me use the real data into for the
four-minute phone calls you win but
you're way worse than AJ well I remember
a TA feedback we read we actually have a
ranking system of every human being
we employ best we don't we have a crm of
people to pick up basketball skills
that's basically how we judge people
like you and my phone
it does matter Harvick know where
company instead of Justice f- bacala
player event there's a single best
product since the icon that's part of 10
years I keep everyone like you look I
think I tweeted that tonight best
product since the iPhone itself I can't
so I did something so much better than
you anticipated they nailed it cereal I
just saw a rock snapchat yep
or and I was like I live right here so
then it was an hour hour go to so I was
like I didn't know if I see you but go
trying on down hey Gary this is surreal
man I was like I didn't know if I see
you but oh my god I'm gonna have this
perfect no worry hell yeah what up
statue I got real place I'm going to do
this oh what's here blah blah blah blah
you know pleasure man thanks for the
love thanks I used to work at a Deloitte
digital doing all kinds of emerging tech
stuff really hot on VR watch a lot of
your videos now we're in my own small
studio making money having a good time
man thank you so much for the
inspirations I can't wait to see where
it goes and I know you've been talking
about it but you kind of stopped
covering it after a bit yeah I mean I
haven't slowed you know like it's very
much top of mind I've you've also heard
me say that you know I think VR
consumers going to be a little bit
longer than a lot of my friends think
right so that's coming it's a long
playoff it's a long flight but it's the
computing well it is the thing that will
orbit ROG the internet itself
thank you so much my man cuz you're in
success thanks let's look take care of
it
for this way that's why I'm really
trying to figure out like how this all
plays out because I'm not going to be
somebody that people are excited to meet
because I can hit a baseball 500 feet or
because I'm a smoke show and gorgeous or
because I get it
but you know I'm hoping that's emerging
it is but it's because I'm doing a good
like it's different it's different it's
different and most people that do what I
do that's different charge people for it
and so when you take the compounded I
understand this tribution in today's
world that are the most I'm charismatic
enough and a good enough communicator to
pull it off my intent is pure luck
I'm not asking for anything in return
and it's predicated on something that
makes your life way better that's why on
my talk this is going to get surreal
[Music]
hey guys we welcome everybody okay in
the rule have been obvious for office
space we've got this section here we've
got that section in there we've got this
is the data panic attack we've done
sales an account
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk I'm the
disproportionate were student here I
went to Mount Ida college I guess we
tried not to go to college but my mom
wouldn't let me pull that off this is
the biggest investment I've ever made in
the company period so what I've framed
my company vaynermedia which is 700
people at this point five offices for
offices really is a honey Empire and I
think that's where you're actually
building you're building the tool that I
need to build my honey Empire a honey
Empire is a company that wants to
destroy every single company it competes
with because it wants to be an empire
and it wants to do it by making people
feel awesome and by empowering their
teammates and by starting with honey
instead of vinegar
I think HR is offense I think 99.9% of
people think of a charged offense
my greatest boom moment of speaking was
when I took the stage of South by
Southwest and shortly after Steve Jobs
died I said [ __ ] Steve Jobs I have no
aspiration to be like him because I did
not like the way he treated other people
and I feel that you could build a
trillion-dollar company by treating
people phenomenally well and that honey
always beats vinegar and then times like
this in our world that a lot of my
friends on certain political issues are
unfortunately disappointing me at a
scale that I didn't expect because
they're deploying vinegar to go after
vinegar and it's honey that always wins
and so I was super passion to be
involved in this company I have no idea
of haikyuu wins I really don't I
definitely hope so for all of you and me
desperate the company that looks like
haikyuu in 2024 that wins is one of the
biggest companies in the world period
because it's tens and tens and hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars that
are saved and companies are empires and
they care about that
and it's honey it makes people feel good
the number two person of my company is
our chief heart officer we didn't call
George are what we call pet people and
experience I don't care as long as it
wasn't called HR because everybody has
it branded this way there's no company
that I'm involved with that people go
around the room and say the things that
hit me in my heart they gave me my
wallet they hit me in my brain they hit
me in my competitive spirit they hit me
my salesmanship they don't hit me in my
soul this is super what it's about for
me and I've been doing this in a non
scalable way like in 2009 I would look
at my employees Twitter accounts and
give them tickets to unfortunately the
Cardinals in this scenario and give them
tickets to a Cardinals game and I
promise you who still works in our
company I think if I gave them a four
times financial raised versus those
tickets it wouldn't have had anywhere
close to the impact people want to be
heard and cared for that's why big data
synthesized properly at scale is the
ultimate so I'm excited cool okay there
between there guys three to let it pay
then no one Jeremy's going to buy the
Darwin how is gonna buy a Range Rover
circa one two three and ready
[Music]
[Music]
really I'm slowing maybe you saw
Gopinath truly I feel like a boss then
every afternoon freestyling versus what
everyone else is that you in the cross
this is my sort of thing as I keep
getting better than more that I try been
on a field I've been out here scoring
their goals but I know that I'm touching
the sky so when I say that I'm ready
just know that a women across it is that
this is the launch of a reading travel
I'm headed there like I've been doing it
already already I've been on the come-up
I see that I'm ready to charge but I
know I gotta be careful cuz I do not
waterfowl star so I'm ready to go to any
place I haven't been already befo better
verbal machete to show anybody heavy if
you want to come and fiddle them at any
a flow gonna study I know and that's
what anybody in a world that don't see
had a very buddy out here on the only
rapid everybody wants a degree well
now another place where between the
skies which was a but now we'll know our
the now ago our cow